today's topic so our situation happened
a while ago
where there's this girl i was intimate
with and
you know everything was good but after a
while i started noticing i didn't go
down on her
and i was like all right let me try to
do let me try to fix that so
i want to go down on her the next time
and
and i hope i don't get hate for this i
love eating but
some reason i just could not muster up
the courage to go down on her
and the curse i started thinking for
myself
because it's not smart are you afraid of
eating
no [ __ ] i love you and i eat ass
all right i'm a booty connoisseur
you know i never i never i never
know what courage but she here's the
thing though
so i started to ask myself so why
and i kind of came to the conclusion
that a part of me feels like
maybe it's because of how her vocal
looks
and so i was going to ask you and for
the people in the comments have you ever
had
that she tried going down on that hold
up just
you know fine did it smell okay no it
smelled fine but
that that's what i'm saying then close
your eyes and go to work
you don't need the c to e
we done here
you don't need to [ __ ] listen um why
you [ __ ] eat
if i can smell the food i can eat the
food hey listen if the food is
is delicious if it tastes fine what's
the issue yo what's this
i don't like the way this stuff flaps
you think every girl likes the way your
dick looks
yo it's big
it's this big come on now it's amazing
look let's be honest
that curve's all funny come on now some
of y'all ain't even like y'all we're not
cut properly some y'all not cut properly
so we are not cut at all
some of y'all yeah she's not peeling it
back to see it's like come on come on
now
come on now come on if it smells fine
yum it off
yeah here you know what you do got a
point but how do you have a point
how is closed your eyes a point this is
a problem with these gen z people
yeah they want to see the truth so bad
they always gotta [ __ ] with the lights
on dude
turn off the lights [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's a reason why they got night
nights
just clap your hands why do you think he
was clapping because he was already butt
naked in bed they didn't have time to go
together
it's just more convenient [ __ ] you mean
but these young kids they always go up
i'm whoa come on [ __ ] go to sleep and
eat that [ __ ] that's it
night night [ __ ] yeah this is coming
from someone
who doesn't do it but i don't do it not
because i don't like the way volvo's
look i just don't do it period
have you had a [ __ ] nobody
nobody asks you to have like a [ __ ]
blink twice if you
need to look at it you look but when you
have sex you'll be looking especially
when you're clapping from behind you'll
be like
always
you don't [ __ ] if you don't get the
[ __ ] up of my life
he was looking at it eye to eye you
don't
that's where the poop come from no i
don't stare at nobody no
no you don't well if it smells fine and
you eat ass
let's go back on that you don't like you
didn't like how the way her
or pom-pom looked like yeah yeah i mean
you didn't like that
but you eat ass you was fine with the
smell but the look was off
but you eat ass
i don't have an answer this just a
question
bottles of mine she smelled fine
you couldn't look at it but you eat ass
boy this new generation boy
it's confusing i was giving you praises
and now you just [ __ ] it up for the
whole generation
huh close your eyes close the lights
limits
right and yummy y'all don't need to be
woke all the time
walk in the streets eyes closing the
streets
okay keep it simple don't complicate it
all right you're gonna meet a girl she
looks great you take her clothes off
don't look that great
turn off the lights it still feels great
it's okay
you're going to be fine you don't need
to see everything no you don't
her silhouette looks great it'll be fine
turn off the lights whole idea i got to
stare at us
and also i don't know i think porn might
have [ __ ] up a lot of people's heads
but of course it has
because they see all these girls with
chopped off labias and all those other
stuff and they'd be like me
that looks doesn't look like what i saw
on the moon so
this is what you see porn is not real do
you think the way that they [ __ ]
is real of course not so why would you
think the real if they titties is fake
and the ass is fake you think their
vaginas look real
i think labia plasti is like one of the
most popular plants it is the thing and
i don't know even though like ladies
it's not worth it it hurts i'm not not
it hurts it's not worth it it hurts it's
horrible
everybody that i've talked to that had
it tell me that
it was almost not worth it it was not
worth it the pain
for for what it and they lose sensation
they little bunch yeah
it's not worth it it's not worth it i
don't like it it looks like i smoked
meat smoked meat is delicious
i got it here great sandwich forgot it
here okay sandwiches
my mine looks like a taco my taco intake
in the past two years
has been to the roof tacos tacos
let's go put some guacamole on that pico
de gallo
a bit of sour cream salsa verde i'm just
saying it's
it's it's crazy how common this stuff is
and it's just important it's like
saying i haven't even heard girls nick
if it's not circumcised like that's
nasty
peel it back it's like a surprise wiener
enjoy it
bring the sexy back peel it back it's
just like it's just like people are like
so fussed over random [ __ ] that have
no bearing and no one points and you
should want her to
have the extra skin it's like good
she'll be extra sensitive
she's got more places for you to work
around that's it work it out
so it's one of those things that people
are like oh how about this dudes would
be like yeah girl
yeah yeah go down on me go down on me
the girl comes back
i'm not gonna kiss you though it's like
not trying to taste but you want her to
taste it so it's too dirty for you
but she can taste it and say
[ __ ] are gonna take her hands
put it on the football and after that
make her taste it oh it's okay for her
to do it but not you yeah
that's like that's like young guy [ __ ]
it's like so stupid yeah you go eat her
you you gonna eat her out but then you
come back up she don't kiss you you
wouldn't find that suss
she's like whatever it's not that deep
men be men be fussed about random [ __ ]
that's not important listen sex is nasty
all right damn right you gotta be a
nasty [ __ ] do it it's a messy
thing
all right so what's your fluids being
exchanged a bunch of stuff
you know touching snatch [ __ ]
get to it eat with your hands
you're gonna get dirty that's right
you're gonna get some of that sauce on
you that's right
okay okay let's go if you're going in
for pleasure
it's supposed to be missing let's go all
right if you're going in the procreate
nobody gets ever ever eat ate a mango
with a knife and fork
go ahead or a pizza with knife and fork
that's
ever seen you go to a restaurant if i go
to a restaurant and put a like a chicken
in front of me
and it's like a the drumstick i don't
care what restaurant i am i'm picking
that [ __ ] with my hands
yup i'm not gonna try to um we're in a
wedding no [ __ ]
you put a damn drumstick in my [ __ ]
plate i'm going in
i don't care for where we eat i'm about
to i'm about to
uh digest this delicious delicacy
yeah i said it again i don't give a [ __ ]
that's how i say delicacy i'm using my
goddamn hands
it's can i say without being there
let me try is that nasty is that good
good they're grown up
knock some boots do some taxes do some
taxes
file them properly yes yes thanks stamp
right
fill that cap that's right you know what
i mean good for you it's
nasty [ __ ] be a nasty [ __ ]
tell them stay nasty it's like you know
the most interesting man
uh that that that the keys
you got to be when it comes to that
thing you have to be the most nastiest
man
the other day stay nasty yeah
if you're not willing to close your eyes
to go please your partner
be a little selfless be a little giving
do what you're not interested in doing
but keep in mind this is coming from
someone who doesn't eat boom boom at all
so whatever
take my advice the grain of salt okay
yeah good hopefully this turns off all
the women
they stop messaging they won't no i'm
gonna make you throw i'm gonna make you
turn i'm
terrible i'm terrible at the bedroom
stuff you know a couple of friends
i'm like about to come about to come and
i'm like i'm already done girl we got to
take a break
listen it doesn't matter no you would
challenge you would turn them all off
you were challenged to them
turn it all off they want they want to
know yeah if you think my shape up here
is terrible
man my ship up down there okay we went
too far is it
no no you ain't got no shape up yeah
tell us what you guys think stay nasty
[Music]
foreign